hallo und herzlich willkommen heute am
freitag
regeneration und mobilisation steht
heute am programm
gestern haben auch ein hochintensives
ausdauer workout mit euch gemacht und
heute wie gesagt zum wochenausklang
machen etwas regeneratives und schau mal
das man bislang beweglichkeit auch in
unsere gelenke hineinbekommen die nici
ist wieder da ich der beta bin da und
heute haben einen spezialgast eine
zweite nicole rupprecht zugführerin
jährige leistungssportlerin und
starterin bei den letzten olympischen
spielen rio 20 16 und welche sportart
sie genau macht besser aktie jetzt am
besten selbst aber ständig kurz vor also
mein name ist mit karl rupprecht wie
schon gesagt ich mache rhythmische
gymnastik und bin seit 2003 zehn jahre
sport dabei mein größter erfolg war die
teilnahme an den olympischen spielen
2016 und hoffentlich war ich halt jetzt
2021 nach tokio auch nicht okay das hast
du machst das jetzt seit wie vielen
jahren genau seit die fünf bin also
braucht man jetzt verraten
aber sag mal 20 jahre ungefähr das ist
konnten aber seitdem fünf bis das heißt
es ist ja mit vom kleinkindalter weg
auch zu trainieren diese beweglichkeit
weil wenn ich jetzt als aber auch schon
amanda sagte ich möchte dem rhythmischen
sportgymnastik machen hätte
wahrscheinlich das problem oder
ja ich glaube da werden die mittel
eingeschränkt das ist sehr höflich
formuliert dankeschön das was wir jetzt
machen wir machen ein kurzes
mobilisieren und aufwärmen und dann
schauen wir uns an wie die beweglichkeit
ist was die nicola für spezial übungen
für uns mitgebracht hat und da schauen
wir wie gut dass man das umsetzen können
um dann beschwingt und mit mehr
beweglichkeit ins wochenende gehen zu
können okay
das heißt wir beginnen lockeres laufen
am stand dass wir das jetzt
kreislaufsystem ein bisschen schwung
bringen die muskulatur ein bisschen
aufwärmen und entsprechend uns
vorbereiten auf das was dann kommt ihr
kind zu hause natürlich schuhe anziehen
kann sich die schuhe ausziehen
klarerweise in dem fall die rhythmische
sportgymnastin hat schuhe ausgezogen
weil gemacht als barfuß oder ja werden
halt anders ist schon dass die trasse
schulen sowie basel
da möchte er die arme vorwärts kreisen
dazu aus dem laufen heraus und eine
rückwärts kreisen gut aus lockt dann
stehenbleiben kopf drehen linke seite
beginnend auf die rechte seite schauen
und wieder wechseln auf die linke seite
mobilisieren im bereich der
halswirbelsäule und die blick wendung
nach oben und nach unten sind sagt dass
kopf neigen dazu unser verständlich auch
heute wieder solltet ihr fragen zum
thema sport in dem fall beweglichkeit
und mobilisation training auch heute
sitzt ddr aus vor dem pc und
beantwortete fragen natürlich sehr gerne
und linke seite beginnen über die brust
rollen auf die rechte seite und der
wechsel wieder zurück
und wir laufen wieder kurzes bewegen
wieder am stand und jetzt schauen wir
uns an ob die rhythmische sportgymnastin
aufgepasst hat die letzten wochen
unseres trainings war das spezial das
bei uns hat auch immer wieder den
bocksaal aufmachen müssen sagen mein
freund wickie boxer lauf bitte also ist
auch nicht mehr aus der ruhe zu bringen
genau mit einem lächeln quittiert box
funktioniert genauso
das ist sehr gut hast du fragen mit
selbstverteidigung und boxen nach gott
sei dank nicht stellt der praktischen
anwendung sondern vielleicht irgendwann
einmal trainingseinheit gemacht hat kann
er vielleicht was in einer oft schießen
was man mal probieren kann
okay was hände in die hüfte becken
kreisen schöne preise machen eine
richtung richtung wechseln
einmal noch vor biegen und nach hinten
biegen also zurück biegen das becken und
dann kleiderwechsel links und rechts
ein kurzer ausschnitt und springen beim
ndr wieder der wechsel natürlich noch
vor zurück und auf und so wechseln mal
wieder in den stand lauf und ihr kreis
gleich den ellbogen im ellbogengelenk
hände seitlich hoch geben locker weiter
laufen und richtung wechseln
genau und bleiben wir aber im laufen
dabei hände zusammen kreis man gleich im
handgelenk ist jetzt wir machen das ganz
allgemein einmal kurz den körper wärme
und dann kann man das spezielle
mobilisieren hineingehen und locker mal
wieder aus was macht man noch nicht wo
sein also nicht zu meiner linken
wachtmeister was macht man kniegelenk
das heißt dem stehen was man hilft
breiten stand kann pendele auf das knie
und chrysler im kniegelenk richtung
wechseln
und sie das lokal eine höchst übung im
stehen ganz viele aber im moment ja dann
muss auf die seite okay gab auf die
seite neigen das heißt üben obendrüber
greifen und gesellschaft wir haben
zumindest in einer ebene alles
hüftgelenk damit dabei und wieder
ausloggen sprunggelenk machen wir dann
hätte gesagt aber am besten im sitzen
weil das ist glaube ich eine deiner
übungen die du zum zustand perfekt
einmal vorzeigen kann
wenn sie fahrzeuge sieht man nicht
setzen uns nieder
wir können sich gern auf dem markt
besetzen ja dafür haben wir es und
mobilisieren das sprunggelenk im sitzen
wie schaut es bei dias also erst einmal
wird man okay das heißt erst einmal
sparen als der wahre herauskriegen genau
das was zu sich ziehen
okay das macht man ja mal und die
position wir haben keinen stress hat man
zumindest einmal 30 sekunden dass man
wirklich hat bislang spannung
herauskriegen ich denke ihr mobilisiert
täglich beim training
ja also es ist sicher große teile des
trainings hinter circa halbe stunde in
anspruch weil wir nur reine spagat denen
machen
und keine sorge wir haben zwar auch nur
eine halbe stunde zeit aber halbe stunde
spagat den mann nicht seite wechseln
macht man eine zweite seite in der
dehnung und wer von euch jetzt ein
problem hat dass die hand zu kurz oder
der fuß zu lang ist das heißt seine
zehen nicht erreicht da kann natürlich
ein handtuch nehmen und das entsprechend
um den fuß herum wickeln und dadurch
dann die hand absoluten hammer bisschen
verlängern
also wird jeder ist von haus aus glamour
so beweglich dass er überhaupt hinkommt
ok langsam wieder den druck heraus und
jetzt geht es weiter
es wird einmal 80 nur zehn strecken okay
sie hinaus strecken und wieder
hochklappen
wichtig ist dass man da die knie strecke
okay das kniegelenk bleibt gestreckt das
ist arbeiter ersten übung ganz wichtig
dann kann man greifen
ok ich erst einmal nach draußen und
einmal nach
okay das heißt immer die richtung
wechseln volle kreise genau und was
sagst du jetzt zum beispiel jemanden
jetzt kommt wer zu dir der haut eine
einschränkung in der beweglichkeit im
sprunggelenk wo kann das herkommen und
wo wie kann man dagegen arbeiten
naja denen ist prozess wo man immer
daran arbeiten kann also jeder der
irgendwo unbeweglich ist es kann man
einfach erlernen und das sich kaum
schützen eine übung es ist ein
sprunggelenk natürlich auch dafür den
für den knöchel ganz wichtig in den zwei
haupt bewegungsrichtungen soll jetzt
einmal noch vor handystrahlung so wie du
bist oder weil man dass die 10 in
richtung knie zurück in den zwei
bewegungen heute natürlich jeweils der
muskel zurück das heißt in die rücke in
der rückwärtigen bewegung ja halt die
wadenmuskulatur das ganze die
beweglichkeit auf und in der
vorwärtsbewegung natürlich da vorne
das schienbein muskel und die zwei
kennen natürlich trainieren das denen
von wadenmuskel haben wir schon einmal
im stehen gemacht wir schauen uns jetzt
nur im sitzen an so bevor er zum
aufwärmen er schnappt euch entsprechend
euren fuß und jetzt der tat um eine
spannung auf in dem er mit fußball gegen
eure hand oder gegen das handtuch drückt
die spannen heute mal zehn sekunden
richtig dagegen drücken noch 5 3 2 1
jetzt die spannung raus nehmen genau und
jetzt sieht es wieder so weit wie es
geht das wenn fuß zurück wie ist es für
dich auch spürbar
ja spannung halten noch zehn sekunden
und es kam drei vier fünf mal ruhig
wiederholen und dann kriegt nur
richtiger schöne beweglichkeit auch da
in die wadenmuskulatur eine dehnung
hinein
okay was noch einmal bei der anderen
seite dass er das prinzip name habt das
heißt zurück sie hält dagegen drücken
gegen die hand das ist volle
muskelspannung noch 5 sekunden und
wieder druck rausnehmen und dann in die
beweglichkeit nach hinten ziehen mit ok
das heißt wir haben schon mindestens
einmal eine variante noch ganz kurz wie
könnte man den schienbein muskel denen
wirklich mal dessen genau das macht man
ja noch ganz kurz dass man das sehen
dass man nicht nur darüber reden
das heißt zehn lang machen draufsetzen
und im normalfall spürt man das schon
ganz gut wenn sie mit bereits auf meine
draufsetzt wohl was ich bin in der
beweglichkeit natürlich nicht so weit
wie wir zwei ja dann spüre ich das schon
und wenn das noch zu wenig ist dann kann
man noch fahren das knie aber anheben
oder soweit anheben
ja dass man doch wirklich anzug hinein
kriegt auch in den muskeln den tipp
jahres genau wie geht's weiter möchte
auch für dich ist es aufwärmen für uns
ein schweres mobilisieren was man in der
regeneration natürlich dann los machen
können
zeiger mal vor eine übung an ihr werdet
bisschen hüftkreisen machen
ein softie und dame legen und dann
einfach versuchen kreise zum zeichnen
mit dem fuß sorgt das schafft jeder von
euch jetzt das vorher ausprobiert man
muss er das bein mit über 90 grad
richtung kopf nach hinten sondern das
kann natürlich abdullah kleiner kreis
auch sein genauso ist es wichtig dabei
entspannte position und der arbeits in
eurem gelenks winkel der heute möglich
ist das heißt schon in die endposition
and gerade die bewegung hinein gehen
aber ob die jetzt bei 150 grad oder bei
75 grad ist ist nicht ganz so tragisch
richtung wechseln
ok
macht es da für dich einen unterschied
ob es 17 gestreckt sein oder gebeugt
sein
also wir als gymnastin kriegen das
eingebauten seit unserer kindheit das
immer zehn strecken
das sind mache ich überall aber ich
finde sogar dass es wenn wir so machen
vielleicht sogar da auch dazu mehr
das heißt im prinzip für die
mobilisation aus der hüfte ist das nicht
vertrage aber gesamtheitlich betrachtet
du als gymnastin strecke zehn okay dann
machen wir die zweite seite noch dazu er
knackt die hüfte
das ist ein guter schlagwort was ist so
das haupt dass das leistungsfähigste
alter eine gymnastin ziemlich
unterschiedlich in den ausblick staaten
sowie in russland das sind sie natürlich
mit 16 zwischen 16 und 18 am besten aber
weil sie halt danach weist ihn kaputt
sind sagen also gut deswegen können sie
eine zu lange touren ich bin jetzt 28
und dem weltweit eigentlich die älteste
ok aktiv weil du einfach kontrolliert
das ganze aufgebaut hast du langsam
trainiert hast also langsam die
fortschrittlich wahrscheinlich gemacht
hast und nicht von jetzt auf gleich
gehen hüfte dicke zu meiner linken fällt
ja auch machst du eine hüft übung für
uns
okay das macht sie glauben das heißt es
ist eine standard übung die quer durch
alle sportarten zum aktivieren oder auch
regenerieren gerne gemacht wird das
heißt die knie richtung boden hinunter
drehen und dabei haben wir schöne
bewegung mobilisation auch im hüftgelenk
dringen kann man natürlich dann auch
variieren indem er die beine zusammen
stellt das modernste momentan in stadlau
wir haben unsere eigene trainingshalle
frau stürzen habe jetzt eine eigene
branche haben ja sehr gut
er werde gott sei dank das bundesheer
für ein halbes jahr die möglichkeit
gehabt dass ich hier in der maria
theresien kaserne trainieren aber jetzt
haben wir unsere eigene trainingsstätte
bekommen dann spart man sieht dass voran
und hat natürlich sehr gerät dort wo man
es braucht und weil ja ganz wichtige
punkte
ok dann kurzem aus locker eine weitere
übung was machst du gern für die hüfte
im schneidersitz herr schneider sie
damals den kleinen okay da schneider
sitzt davor ist dazu ein
ich habe letztens mit meinen kindern
geplant und die haben gesagt nicht
schneidersitz papa zu anderen
schmetterlings sitzen und dann setzt
sich der große hin schmetterlings ist
und das machen wir jetzt einmal und
schlagen mit den flügeln und das habe
damals gefunden hat das will ich euch
nicht vorenthalten
vielleicht kann es an motivation sein
eure kinder zur bewegung zu bringen das
heißt es immer etwas kindlicher
aufzubauen aber bitte erzähl weiter im
schneidersitz das zeitliche
rumpfmuskulatur beziehungsweise breite
rückenmuskulatur muss kommen da rein in
die dehnung
wir haben das letzte mal mit der
synchronschwimmerin mit der vag ob die
hat immer statisch zuerst gearbeitet und
dann dynamisch habt ihr es auch geht die
wechsel mama dynamischer bäume hin und
ja
und dass man mit dem korb also wir
versuchen das immer die ganze
wirbelsäule zum denen probleme im kopf
und sich dann abholen lassen bis man
versucht den kopf auf die füße zu
bringen aber geschafft hätte ich nicht
jeder aber weder jeder hast du schaffst
das aber wir okay fast verstanden danke
macht es da anziehen wenn man vorsichtig
und locker eine unterstützung hat dass
man sagt okay man nimmt sich am 2
da bist du die schwerkraft quasi
unterstützt natürlich aber nicht
vorsicht mit vorsicht also wenn ihr zu
zweit zuhause wirklich den dem der
gedehnt wird auf den höheren und sagen
es reicht dann reicht es wirklich also
nicht über gebühr da draufdrücken und
dann schauen was vielleicht irgendwann
einmal mit dem mit der stirn zu den
zehenspitzen
ja es wird dir das mal ist okay ich habe
das volk sagt ihr seid eine halbe stunde
im spagat wie bereitet hat die übung vor
wir bereiten uns so vor dass manchmal
versuchen in dieser position versuchen
dass man die mit den händen die knie
nach hinten drücken
ich sehe schon dass ist position da ist
die hüft beweglichkeit sicherlich einer
der bestandteile die ganz wichtig ist
was gibt's denn dafür möglichkeiten dass
man da überhaupt einmal rein kommt weil
ich denke mal das ist einmal super
schwer überhaupt die position zu halten
vermag meister vor dir da übungen
okay ich hab jetzt deswegen die vormacht
meister charakter wenn das wenn das du
magst und auseinander rutscht bereits im
spagat da dann haben wir von der übung
nichts mehr
deswegen bitte einmal bei dir nach
hinten bewegen das becken drews die
vielleicht einmal 90 grad an dass man
das von der seite aussehen da sind kann
ich die kurz einrichten
das heißt die kniegelenk ganz weit
auseinander
ihr könnt die beine gerade nach hinten
oder hinten zusammen gehabt und da
kriegt einfach einen unterschiedlichen
druck hinein
wichtig ist jetzt dass der rücken gerade
bleibt vielleicht sogar eine leichte
hohlkreuz position er hineingeht und
dann den oberkörper das becken nach
hinten schiebt er kennt sein mal vorne
am ellbogen abstützen
genau wie darum gerade rücken leicht ins
hohlkreuz vielleicht genick gedrückt
durch noch einmal hoch und jetzt drückt
sich nach hinten durch genau jetzt in
der position keine perfekte in der hüfte
mobilität arbeiten das wiederholen 30 40
50 mal so wie es zeitlich für euch ganz
gut passt und dann langsam aufstehen bei
eine ausschüttung weil das ist eine
richtige belastung für sucht gelenke
also das ist eine übung die geht richtig
rein in unterschiedlichsten positionen
wie gesagt aufstehen auslagern und die
habe von einer physiotherapeutin vom am
ball wirklich toller physiotherapeut wir
haben da mal probleme gehabt und mit
einer fortbildung gemacht und der hat
uns sagt das wollten wir euch natürlich
nicht vorenthalten auch diese übung hier
zu machen ok bitte geht's weiter
die schultern bienen okay das heißt
beweglichkeit mobilisieren aus der
schule heraus wie schaut das für dich
aus was macht ihr da tatsächlich
versuchen ihr sagte achter wir haben
gesagt das sind wie wie einen tee
servieren also das team cups surfing
das heißt ihr fangt an wenn man das
einmal langsam sodass ihr mitmachen
kennt sie nehmen wir alle die rechte
hand lassen wir die fingerspitzen einmal
nach vorn schauen
dann zieht man den ellbogen zurück jetzt
arbeiten wir mit den fingerspitzen nach
aussehen
die beweglichkeit kommt im tor ist im
schultergelenk nach hinten die
fingerspitzen so
was wenn ihr die teetasse auf der
handfläche hätte dass sie nicht
runterfällt jetzt über den kopf auf die
andere seite
jetzt schauen die fingerspitzen wieder
nach vor er hat sich richtige bewegung
da in der schulter trainern wieder nach
außen und jetzt holen wir wieder herein
das heißt diese runde achter oder pick
up service können sich gern als
vorstrafe legt sich am ball traf lag
zwischen schuh traf nicht probieren den
schläger bei den schuh auf den
handflächen und der darf nicht ob ich
vorhin ja und nicht greifen das ist klar
das kann jeder sondern fingerbreit
finger lang und dann nach hinten nach
außen rückwärts über den kopf macht und
wir kommen wieder in die endposition
wagner und das mit einer möglichst
stabilen oberkörper mit einer möglichst
aufrechte position
das machen wir gleich noch zweimal und
einmal noch und jetzt jetzt spürt dass
die beweglichkeit in der schulter die
wird gefordert und die kerne damit
wirklich cool verbessern
das kann in die andere richtung machen
wir fangen über innen an außen über kopf
der gleiche kreis nur in der anderen
richtung begannen machen wir das
vielleicht an und zwar dreimal dasteht
wir an ok maßnahme langsam mit gebietet
zum zum mitmachen für euch zu hause
das heißt hand nach innen drehen außen
über kopf nach vor so schwer ist jetzt
aber nein aber wenn man mal langsam mal
mitmacht dann kommt man da schon ganz
gut rein
am 1 genau jetzt passt zweite seite
zweiter hand fangen wir wieder an nach
hinten zieht zurück fingerspitzen nach
außen fingerspitzen zurück fingerspitzen
über kopf nach vor drehen und über die
seite wieder hereinkommen in den kreis
zweites mal zurück nach außen hinten
über kopf nach vor und wieder den kreis
fertigmachen ein drittes mal noch
und wenn ihr sowas zb in der kraftkammer
oder in eurem fitnessstudio ja
vielleicht zu hause ja eine hantel
scheiben so halver kilo liegt straff
fans perfekt arbeiten tennisball was
auch immer drauf legen
darunter fallen lassen und das genau
damit dabei zweite richtung
das heißt wir beginnen wieder nach innen
genau nach hinten nach außen nach vor
über kopf nach hinten außen und wir
sahen wieder in unserem kreis fertig
zweites mal genauer erklärte album
zuerst einmal hinaus und einmal noch
also wenn die richtung nicht ganz stimmt
und die drehung nicht ganz richtig ist
das überhaupt kein problem solange dort
in zug die drehung die rotation im
schultergelenk trainiert und ybbs passt
super letzte variante das ist natürlich
auch eine möglichkeit er macht das mit
beiden händen gleichzeitig jetzt ist
aber so was funktioniert sind den
meisten fällen immer dass sie den
oberkörper wirklich aufrecht lassen kann
sondern es muss in einer person
mitnehmen
das heißt wir ziehen einmal zurück
gemeinsam drehen die fingerspitzen nach
außen nach hinten über kopf jetzt müssen
wir doch vorbeugen
ja und jetzt wollen sie draußen wieder
nach vor und das wirklich ein super
super beweglichkeit im schultergelenk
drinnen wenn man das regelmäßig macht
kam als sie da wirklich stark verbessern
und das ist für so viele sportarten
haben wir bereits gehört und mitbekommen
ach so wichtiger punkt die beweglichkeit
aus dem schultergelenk heraus das heißt
die übung kann man einfach regelmäßig
machen und dann haut es wirklich
supergut ihn okay das was weiter nur ein
was ist wichtig für dich als
sportgymnastin das rhythmische
sportgymnastin wie trainierst du noch
die oberschenkelrückseite genau die
beweglichkeit der heraus die dehnung in
der dynamik in der statik das heißt was
macht
wir versuchen natürlich die hände am
boden zu bekommen aber wenn man das
nicht schafft ist eine hier versucht das
mit ihrem 18
wir gehen nach unten dann immer nach
oben und wenn man nach oben gehen mit
der nase die knie zu kommen aber immer
sagt wir haben auch die wachtmeister
hatte extreme beweglichkeit im
verhältnis zum otto normalverbraucher
wie sie bin insofern ist dieser
vorschlag ist unfair dass sofort zu
zeigen es seien nur die lockere variante
mit dir vor was kann ich machen wenn ich
das so nicht schaffe rechnet von oben
nach unten genau so weit wie kommt mit
mit geraden rücken oder mit rundrücken
was es nicht gerade mit geradem rücken
und die grenze bereits die hammer als
den übung bereits gehabt das heißt aus
der luft breiten stand gerade rücken
hände verschränken nach vor bewegen und
ihr kriegt star den zug in die
oberschenkelrückseite hinein
und da ich dann ganz egal ob da wirklich
darf den wir bieten das ein bisschen
oben bleibt ja raffauf ob der winkel so
ist wo viele von uns bereits anzug
spüren oder oberhalb wesentlich weiter
und ist ja okay also das ist dann wie
gesagt überhaupt kein kein problem wird
fand die übung ist er wichtiger die
machen wir gleich auch als den übungen
das heißt arme in die opposition hinein
finden 30 sekunden position halten
spannung herausnehmen spannung lösen und
dann entsprechend wieder langsam aus der
opposition heraus kommen staatenlos
hüftbreit der stand gerade oberkörper
hände verschränken schultern
zurückziehen
gerade bleibt rücken bis in die
opposition hinein
ok und jetzt position halten und
versuchen da diese 30 sekunden spannung
zu lösen und dafür euch noch mal zu
hause als erinnerung des dänen kader
gewisser zug spürbar sein aber ich suche
jetzt ein stechender schmerz da sein das
heißt in die beweglichkeit
hineinarbeiten einen zug spüren passt
stechender schmerz dann ein bisschen
nach oben gehen das wäre zu viel
sehen sie konnten noch 321 langsam
wieder aus der opposition heraus kommen
ok langsam hochkommen beine ausschütteln
aber durch lockern
gibt es eigentlich spezielle übungen die
ihr für die wirbelsäule am markt um die
mobilität zu verbessern
ja keine natürlich auch viele vom yoga
das noch einfach mal so in der hunde
stellung ist und dann kurzstrecken in
die cobra genau das stück bevorzugen
ok dann würde ich vorschlagen
wir machen wir es jetzt mal in zeitlupe
für die es die pid ist die bewegung ganz
klar wir uns für euch zu hause ist sie
vielleicht nicht ganz langsam was machst
du mit den händen du gehst nach vorsorge
nach vorne ja versucht und versuche sie
so gut geht durch zu strecken
ok diese position heute machen auch
heute noch mal zu mindestens 20 sekunden
um die position dass der beweglichkeit
und dann der den unterhalt mitarbeiten
noch 10 5 langsam aus der position
wieder heraus
und wieder nach hinten durch genau und
jetzt ganz zurück wir sitzen wieder auf
den unterschenkeln traf hände lang und
versuchen auch hier möglichst entspannt
zu sein und dann wechselt sie dynamisch
hin und her oder in super
geschwindigkeit aber aber zumindest so
dass man noch mit schauern kennen also
nach vor durch und wieder zurück zehnmal
ist gut dann bitte nicht die einzige 210
x und ihr wählt natürlich auch eure
geschwindigkeit zu hause so dass ihr das
gut mitmachen könnt das muss jetzt
geschwindigkeitsrekord werden aber in
der dynamik der bewegung ist es
natürlich auch wiederum eine variante an
der mobilisation dazu arbeiten also wenn
ihr nicht verzockt fünf horst köhler
dann geht es gleich weiter
wie viele stunden drin ist du am tag
es kommt immer darauf an wie gut die
denn hier war mein ziel ist es immer pro
gerät zu mindestens drei gute übungen zu
machen dauert meistens zu wenn ich nach
vier stunden langsam 5 stunden pro tag
zu tag der wahnsinn also richtig richtig
hohen trainingspensum richtig hohe
trainingsbelastung ok stehe mehr auf
lockern wir uns aus was meinst du den
leuten zu hause mitgegeben was ist ein
ganz wichtiges deiner sicht jetzt wo es
zu spät ist wo man nicht rauskommen
wie gestaltet du deinen tag abgesehen
von training also ich finde es sehr
wichtig dass neue stundenpläne sich
vielleicht selber schreibt oder sich
selber kleine ziele vornimmt
die mir dann einheitlich in der woche
das heißt der struktur im tagesablauf
durch die über die woche was man wie
gesagt einfach da mit dabei bleibt dass
man sich selbstlos auferlegt genau das
ist ja ganz wichtiger punkt okay ich
sage danke den zwei damen für eine nette
halbe stunde beweglichkeit training ich
hoffe ihr habt das zuhause gut mitmachen
können und auch entsprechend ab ist
somit erholen können
regeneriert und vielleicht die ein oder
andere beweglichkeit verbessern können
das war es von uns heute wir freuen uns
auf montag auf die nächste einheit und
ja ich würde vorschlagen
schönes wochenende bewegen mobilisieren
jeden tag und am montag sehen wir uns
gemeinsam zum nächsten training
dankeschön